[Musique]
tu as écrit ça
quand toute ma
[Applaudissements]
vie je vous demande d'accueillir
[Musique]
ça va
être c'est la musique du
peuple vous êtes vraiment une
superst je suis pas une
superstar on peut pas séparer la musique
et le
message vous savez
le ça unifie le
peuple tout le monde n'aime pas ce que
tu racontes ta sécurité il faut que tu
[Musique]
arrêtes le 3 décembre 1976 un groupe
d'homme armé a fait irruption au
domicile de B pour tuer le chanteur sa
femme vous en faites pas pour
çaimz bien celle-l
oui ici c'est la guerre comment je peux
amener la paix j'arrive même pas à
amener la pai en
[Musique]
moi
parfois le messager doit devenir le
[Musique]
message
Bob je sais que c'est
dangereux mais tu es le seul capable de
rassembler les
gens tu es prêt
Bob aucune arme ne peut arrêter mon
message je veux que le monde
change et là c'est le moment
[Applaudissements]
this is my m to
you